2109 at a 21-11 they entered the
building by force and they interrupted
the ACT
and separated the perpetrator and the
victims and we assumed that in doing
that they saved the lives of many people
the perpetrator
LED
to the first floor when the federal
forces arrived and then he took his own
life so we are dealing with Aid
fatalities
afterwards
further
horses
arrived on site obviously it was a
large-scale operation of the police in
Hamburg also of the fire department of
the Emergency Services
we have a prepared concept for these
kind of events and it was
implemented very professionally and
comprehensively last night we were not
quite sure at the time whether there
might be a second perpetrator that
turned out not to be the case
to you and very quickly and very
comprehensively the injured were looked
after
all
those that needed
um psychological care
relatives the eyewitness the people
involved in this crime one cannot
imagine what people went through that
were immediately involved in this attack